осінь суперник у вас не мартін шульц і
планом і став тією крон словом не матч він
і я та ангела меркель
ті двоє за дружину ширші за них знають.
потрапили тис шульц як президент
європарламенту мер колах європейський
antique рожевий менеджер хто шпори може
на виборах поривала шульця вин
популярний новачук
упереджений іри увійти у пари он і я
кандидату канцлер і вельможі елінор уват
і справді щуку а літію у берліні
оскільки довгому ряду вайран не на
лижах
ти парвін відпочиваю вибір типу бентеж
рейтингу соціал-демократів зростання та латинь
людина вірить мартін шульц
вже мати і але сватається до людей вин
посилається нас виду sweet as we
background сама тому його політичні
заяви звучати біляш за довідковим
вин говорити про владний до світлиці
роботі впоперек він lavish або ефектами
ебаться інго шульце давши читку відразу мід
і для нього волокна від і на соціально
справедливість розкриті килими форму
брати це соціального забезпечення своєю
владні парті програму 2010 шульц
назвали захистимо авраам фірми так вже
пропускалося а суму німа
нічого вагоні багато овочів ну - ведені
свої помилки до їх образу треба виправляти
і ми ви знали свої полиці
[оплески]
поривів а меркель та й політично богиня
місяць вчить varta балу ту і ти на посаду
канцлера та негою на острові драгу валу
накритих у шульця ходу програми 2010
я нову йому дзвонив їм а формуємо умай
будні та вуса добрі називаємо своїм ім'ям
маркою вчений України з 2005 року до
священний глобальне ліжко в вона
вижила у фінансового щура чи щура євро
вони її політика з диво біженців може
зевсу ватою подалі кар'єру
ринок на ситуації співучість і багато
німці мажу його baruch між свічки на
won't occur ізава менеджера ангелу
меркель можна сказати ще мартін
шульц між священною олаф деки сферах
вин можна його він і такий майстерний
звіту до ситуації ви нак на меркель
гострими шанс знову промах ти
допомогою їх не рей-тян і йдуть у реван
довгий час мер кальво жало інший час
потужну він від партій на Петренка
засіки ще раз щура біженців азаз а я
і німецькі вибрати чоловікові і ось чим
розбити ж стомлюється видно і
їм шубу боку мартин шульц з чіпований
просто вигляд і свою програму та довести
heavens дати вранці від і популярнішою своєю
партії на такому вже рівні шульців і проти
ерколь zoho плеча дуель результати
виборів складно передбачати